Sara starts off this hour in New York
City hi Sara welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thank you so much for
taking my call
sure what's up I have a question about
the end of the baby step two I need help
negotiating my last student loan sorry
I'm really excited I'm really nervous
just a little bit of background I'm a
regular income from the classical
soprano in New York City and I'm about
to go into a dry spell over the summer
and I want to get this done by the end
of June and it feels like a huge
roadblock I've paid off $65,000 and okay
kiddo you're almost there okay I can see
the finish line
so you're paid off 65 how much is the
how much is the students how much 8686
is okay 9600 bucks all right I gave my
first offer of a thousand and there's a
bunch of collection fees on top of it
with the company who's managing it with
a home office they're in st. Louis is
this a this is a sort is this a Sallie
Mae loan no it's not this is private
student loan Sallie Mae is going to be
done by May this is my last one okay and
are you behind on this loan way way
behind I haven't made a payment and so
on I can't even remember okay so
basically you have an unsecured loan a
private loan that happened to be used
for tuition so we're calling it a
student loan and because a government
loan you won't be able to negotiate the
balance so as it's got a government
guarantee on it but this is 8600 all our
principal balance and it's been years
since it's been paid on correct okay and
what are they saying the balance is
total the Home Office says 8686 is
principal the collection agency says 19
k with fees motives and then I made my
first offer yet on Friday for a thousand
and they came back
today with 11:6 oh that's a nice move
but we're not there yet so much how much
can you have by June 1 before your dress
royal starch by June 1 I think I can
have maximum 4 or 5 if I really hustle
that's about max right now I have about
23 said I could give them today all
right well the answer is you know
there's no magic pill to this it's these
guys have obviously figured out that
they're not going to get 19,000 and they
kind of feel like well let's see what
sure what she really does because she
made a ridiculous offer no we're gonna
make an $11,000 offer which they kind of
it's pretty serious
nice nice move on their part nice move
on the chessboard so you know I would
just start to have a conversation and go
listen this is not really about a
negotiation
this is about I just don't have much
money and I want to clear this I really
don't have a lot of money and so I can
negotiate with you but I don't have the
money and so it doesn't you know I you
know the most I could go would be right
now and I would use an odd number I have
40 333 dollars that I can get you by the
forty three hundred and thirty-four
dollars that I can get you by the end of
May and that's I've done detailed
calculations and that's the most I'm
gonna be able to do and then see what
they do you you know and just say that's
all I got guys I mean you can't I can't
negotiate and make money you know your
negotiating technique is not gonna make
me have money I just don't have it okay
and and here's the thing no one has ever
been murdered over settling alone hmm so
death is not an option in this
discussion you're gonna be fine it's
it's a game it's a game so you are
you're a world-class singer obviously
okay and yet when you go to
audition you get rejected most of the
time still don't you yes okay that's all
this is you haven't died from being
rejected as a matter of fact you have
made a career of being rejected yeah you
made it because being rejected is how
you get to be accepted and when you get
accepted when you get the part that's
when you you know that's what your
career is built on right yeah and so
that's all this is this is like okay I'm
gonna go take a shot at this part if I
don't get it my life's not gonna end I'm
gonna get another part and I'm gonna
take a shot at these goobers and see if
I can get them to do forty three hundred
and thirty four dollars by the end of
May and if they flop in the floor and
foam at the mouth or something that's
fine so what it's just part of the drama
right halves back off from this
emotionally and have some fun with it
okay if they smell those tears that I'm
hearing they're gonna slit your throat
kiddo yeah you need to get real arrogant
about this and just have some fun with
it okay step back it's a Monopoly game
it's a game step back from and
emotionally enjoy the the sword fight
that you're in okay okay because nobody
here is gonna die you're gonna be great
you're gonna get this now I don't know
exactly what they're going to take
there's no way of knowing but I suspect
based on this initial move that you're
going to be somewhere you know south of
7,000 bucks is going to settle this
that's just my yes but I don't know
exactly and you might get the forty
three hundred dollar deal I'm just
making that number up by the way I was
just random say because it's again it's
just again keep in mind is the guy on
the other side like I don't know the
side the phone he has it it's just his
job it's not his money exactly it's not
and it's right at the home office and
he's just super patient oh really
it's very calmly gun die yeah so they're
not me it's one person it's just a job
it doesn't come after me it's not even
these guys just got a job and it's not
even a really good
job he has to collects them loan debt I
mean what a crappy job you know and so
you know it's just a job for him and and
you know so keep in mind they are not as
nearly as emotionally tied to this money
as you are because it's not their money
yeah this is a game enjoy you tell me
not to cash out my tiny bit of
retirement oh no this is a game don't
cash it out it's a game write it it's
how many years have been how many years
have been since you paid on this oh my
god probably at least five okay so if it
goes another year what's the matter I
don't want it I don't want it to I want
you to be debt-free but in the in the
scope of your life
don't let them own you over your
decision to be debt-free by summer
don't let them own you just play with
this you're fishing you're fishing set
the hook kiddo set the hook you can do
this you call me back if you need some
more help this is fun this is the Dave
Ramsey show